the realm do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of Aegon's
enemies a story we agreed to tell each
other over and over till we forget that
it's a lie what's up ladies and
gentlemen welcome back for another Game
of Thrones Season eight predictions
video a few months ago I made a couple
different videos where I predicted the
fate of basically every main character
from Game of Thrones in today's video I
want to tell you what I think will
happen to every character that is still
active in the current story now what I
mean by that is I only want to mention
the characters that were in season 7
because we can almost guarantee we will
see them again when it comes to
characters like Daario naharis Jack and
agar and kinvaras
there is no solid evidence that shows
they're coming back for the final season
since there are so many characters still
alive I don't want to waste anyone's
time by mentioning characters we may
never see again so at that being said
let's begin let's start off the video
with Arya Stark when it comes to
predicting the fate of Arya Stark
this is one of the characters that
always leaves me undecided in the end I
always go back and forth with what I
think will happen to her by the end of
the show one day I think she will live
and then the next day I think she will
die but I want to give you a definitive
answer in this video
the actress Maisie Williams who plays
Arya Stark posted a photo to her
Instagram when she finished filming her
scenes for the final season the photo
generated a lot of buzz throughout our
community not only because of what was
shown but mostly because of what she
said in one of her hashtags she said
goodbye Belfast
goodbye Arya goodbye Game of Thrones
what a joy I've had here's to the
adventures to come then she left
hashtags that said last woman standing
and the other one said barely now
everyone should know the actors and
actresses from Game of Thrones are not
allowed to spoil anything this would be
a breach of contract which could cost
them a lot of money but some people took
this Instagram post to heart as if she
was actually given away a big plot point
this does not mean all the other woman
in the show will die except Arya it
means she was one of the last ones to
film these scenes by the looks of her
shoes it appears like she was filming
some kind of fight scenes but the big
question is whose blood is then could
that be arias blood or the blood from
the person she was fighting or killing I
would like to think that is someone
else's blood and just so I can keep this
short and simple I want to play a short
clip from season 7 that will give my
answer about whether or not Arya Stark
survives the show come leave a fool here
a boy you pre thanks
take care of yourself up by try not to
get killed
oh wait I'm not you re I'm a survivor
hot pie is absolutely correct Arya Stark
is a survivor and I now believe she will
make it to the end of the show and
beyond she will kick some white Walker
ass in the north then she will travel
down to King's Landing when it comes
time to deal with Cersei Lannister the
final season will be a very bloody
season but I want to go on record and
say Arya Stark survives all the battles
to come
I'm gonna go ahead and say the same
thing about Hawkeye - we might not see
him again but since we did see him in
season seven I figured he should get a
mention arya told him not to get himself
killed
and he said he won't because he's a
survivor just like her oddly enough even
though he's not a fighter he's right he
has been in the show ever since season
one and he somehow been able to survive
all the bloodshed now the reason why I
think we could see him again is because
of his location he works at the end at
the crossroads which is fairly close to
King's Landing Jaime Lannister will be
heading north so he might stop here on
his way up there or we could see Jon
Arya or whoever else from the north stop
here on their way down to kill Cersei
Lannister all of the main characters
will be changing locations next season
which increases the chances of us seeing
Hawkeye again and if we do I think he
survives just like he told Arya the next
character I want to talk about is dollar
ascend Lord Commander at Castle black I
hate to say it but he's a dead man
walking he has always been a minor
character and he's just the kind of
character I could see them killing off
very early next season it doesn't affect
the plot if he dies early but what it
does do is raise the threat level of the
night king and his army now I know the
night king did kill a dragon but other
than that it's hard to take them serious
when every single time they have our
main character surrounded they always
find a way to escape we need to see the
night King start killing off people we
know and love in order to spread fear
throughout Westeros the night king has
to start wiping out the north as he
makes his way down closer and closer to
Winterfell and King's Landing
unfortunately that means characters like
Dolores
Alysse Karstark little net number we'll
be the first people we know by name to
die next season in order to truly raise
the steaks next season it's finally time
we start seeing the night King inflict
some serious devastation to the realm
not only will Lord Commander EDD die but
I think we might even see him come back
as a white 102 men stop 100,000
well the dies lost be a good lot and the
rest of us I'm done with this world I
don't want to come back I'm sorry baby
but edie is dead and that goes for you
too
little Ned umber and Elise Karstark they
will be added to the night Kings army
before episode 3 they are right in his
path in the night King will be coming
down on them before they even know what
hit them
welcome to the final season of Game of
Thrones ladies and gentlemen it's time
for characters to die speaking of dead
men walking
beric Dondarrion will not make it out of
season 8 alive either if the show
followed the books the entire time
berrak would have been gone many seasons
ago but like I've said before I think
they're keeping an ace up their sleeve
until next season in the books beric
Dondarrion has a special ability he's
able to raise the dead but it comes at a
cost he has to give his own life in
order to raise that dead person this is
how lady Catelyn comes back as Lady
Stoneheart it's too late for beric
Dondarrion to do this in the show now
but that doesn't mean he can't do this
for another character and I believe he
will give the kiss of life to Sandor
Clegane I made a video about this
already and if you would like to hear
all my reasons for why I think this I
will put the link to that video down
below basically beric Dondarrion story
has been intertwined with both of the
Clegane brothers since the very first
season he has been killed by both of
them but in the crazy turn of events
berrak will end up giving his own life
to save the man who killed him
this will eventually lead to the Hound
killing his brother which is the same
person Ned Stark sent beric Dondarrion
after in the first season Lord beric
Dondarrion
you shall have the command assemble 100
men and writes a cigarette Gorsky
as you command I think this would be a
cool way to wrap up all these different
loose ends but keep in mind I am a
knower of nothing since I've already
mentioned both Clegane brothers I might
as well scratch them off the list right
here the mountain dies but his brother
the hound lives now I know there are
other theories out there about who will
kill the mountain but it doesn't make
much sense to me these two men have a
history together dating all the way back
to the hounds birth plus we all remember
the story Littlefinger told us during
the tourney Sandor Clegane will carry
these scars for the rest of his life not
only was he scarred physically but also
emotionally and psychologically he has
hated his brother ever since and he even
admitted that this hate was one of the
very few things that drove him I was
gonna give you a proper burial and then
you cooked Oh nearly [ __ ] myself
I reckoned you were gonna die by the
time I loaded you on the wagon but you
didn't now I reckon he died dozen more
times over the next few days but you
didn't what kept you going ate well they
finally met again at the dragon pit and
I think he made it very clear what would
happen the hound said you know who's
coming for you brother you've always
known he has known this since the day he
shoved his little brother said into the
fire the hound will return this favor
tenfold but he will not be able to just
kill him with a sword
now that the mountain is already dead it
will take a different weapon to put him
down for good
now what is the only weapon the Hound
would be afraid to use that would be
fire he can't just kill his brother he
also needs to get over his fear of the
flames but he can kill two birds with
one stone by killing his brother with
fire since the mountain is basically a
white he will need to die by fire and
the Hound is the only person I can see
doing that it would be the most
satisfying way to end his story in my
opinion with fire and blood for some
reason people seem to think this would
be fanservice but that's only because of
the show watcher
have hyped this up so much i think
george RR martin was planning to do this
all along i mean how do you expect fans
to react when you tease a fight between
two badass brothers that hate each other
at the beginning of the story I mean it
can't be a coincidence that both of
these characters basically died already
but somehow they're both still around
long enough to tease it one last time in
season seven before we finally get the
big showdown in season 8 now let's go
over the handful of characters that I
think are guaranteed to live until the
end Sam Gilley and baby Sam will live I
would actually be very surprised if one
of them died because for some reason I
just don't see that happening I feel the
same way about Podrick Payne Brienne of
Tarth
missandei Lyanna Mormont Meera Reed
Davos Seaworth
and even Gendry I think all of these
characters will live until the end and I
would be a little surprised if any of
these characters died now let's go over
a handful of characters that I think are
guaranteed to die before the end grey
worm dead as I have said before I think
grey worm will die in battle Yan Royce
dead I think he will also die in battle
Varys dead as we all know Melisandre
said Varys would die in Westeros and I
happen to think he will be burned alive
Melisandre dead not only did she save
Varys would die but she said she would
die in Westeros too which means we will
see this happen at some point after she
comes back from volantis Melisandre will
perform one last sacrifice but this time
she will have to give herself up for the
greater good
Joran Greyjoy dead I think you're on
will be killed by another Greyjoy
it could be fian or it could be Yara you
can take your pick as we all know Theon
is currently on his way to rescue his
sister Yara who is being held prisoner
by euron greyjoy
one of them will kill you're on during
this rescue attempt or they will kill
him sometime later if he doesn't happen
to be there when Fiona arrives to get
his sister Cersei Lannister dead Queen
Cersei will make it until the very end
but she will be killed there is no way
in hell she makes it out of the series
alive either Euron Greyjoy kills her to
take the Iron Throne for
self or Jaime Lannister welcome back
down to King's Landing and takes Cersei
out for good or maybe Daenerys just
torches the entire city burning everyone
alive inside of the red keep either way
Cersei will die Jaime Lannister dead
I've said this in a few other videos
already so most of you should know what
I think happens to Jamie by the end I
think he will die in battle by either
saving one of the Starks or at least
helping the Starks this was already set
in motion when Jamie left Cersei to
honor his commitment to Jon and Daenerys
now let's talk about tormund Giantsbane
I go back and forth all the time when
trying to predict what will happen to
tour men sometimes I think he will die
and other times I think he will live
because he is the only leader and
representative of the wildlings that we
know by name I do have to say I would
love to see him survive all the
bloodshed because I think he deserves to
have his own house there should be a
house Giantsbane in the end but
unfortunately I think tormund Giantsbane
will die he came very close to dying
last season when he went beyond the wall
with Jon and company then he almost died
again when he was standing atop the wall
when the night king brought it down as
much as I loved this character I think
his time is up next season tormund will
die and Jaime will die but Brienne of
Tarth will live I think she will lose
both of the men that have some affection
for her I'm gonna go ahead and say Theon
and Yara will both live too but not
without a cost we already know about the
price Theon had to pay and although I
don't think Yara will suffer as much as
he did I still think some bad things can
happen to her before Theon gets there to
save her she could end up getting raped
and impregnated by urine or one of his
men or she could even have her tongue
cut out among many other things
Theon might be able to rescue her but
she will not get away scot-free that's
just my opinion now let's talk about
Jorah Mormont I happen to think he will
live for some reason I just don't think
it would make a whole lot of sense to
cure this character from greyscale in
one season just to kill him in the next
if they were gonna kill him they should
have did it beyond the wall when they
were outnumbered and surrounded but
since they did not kill him when facing
those odds I think he will make it until
the end besides we all
no he needs to reunite with this family
and be seen as an honorable man again in
the eyes of the north we already know
John has respect for Jorah but he needs
the closure when his family and I happen
to think we will see this play out sir
Bronn of the Blackwater will also live
and get his castle
just like with Arya Stark sir Bronn of
the Blackwater is a survivor this man
just always finds a way to pull through
and I think he will pull through until
the very end now when it comes to Qyburn
this is a different story I don't think
he will make another King's Landing
alive euron greyjoy could kill him just
to get him out of his way or in some
crazy turn of events the mountain could
turn on him and kill him or if history
repeats Jamie will killed the Pyromancer
right before he kills the mad queen just
like he did when King Aerys said on the
Iron Throne and threatened to burn them
all we also know King's Landing will
burn to a certain extent
maybe Qyburn gets trapped inside while
everything was on fire who knows I
happen to think Jon and Daenerys will
both live but like I've said many many
times before I would also not be
surprised if either one of them died I
have always had a bad feeling that one
of them would die by the end but for the
sake of this video I'm gonna go ahead
and say John and Daenerys survived all
the fighting and Daenerys will survive
her pregnancy now another chances of
this happening might be low but screw it
they will both live in my opinion but
this is subject to change
last season we are songs as say the lone
wolf dies but the pack survives now that
all the remaining Starks will be
together I'm gonna go ahead and say they
will live we have seen enough Starks
died over the course of the series so I
think it's time this family gets a break
Sansa bran Arya and even John we'll all
live I know this is a risky prediction
because the family has been marked for
death ever since the pilot episode but
by the grace of the old gods they will
persevere in the end now I have to give
a spoiler warning before I talk about
the next character if you do not want to
hear any spoilers you should back out
right now I have always thought
Tyrion Lannister would survive the show
and even the books but a freaky doctor's
information is correct then that means
tearing a Lannister will die in the
season 8 finale
according to his sources Tyrion will be
convicted of treason and sentenced to
death I do not want to believe this
mostly because I do not want it to
happen but unfortunately Fricke doctor
tends to have accurate sources I hate to
say it but we might loose carrying a
Lannister at the dragon pit the last
character on my list is Howland Reed I
thought about leaving him off because
not only was he not in season seven but
we haven't seen him at all however I am
still holding out hope he will show up
in the finale
I mean George are Martin did always say
we would see him show up by the end of
the story so I'm thinking the show could
do the same now most people think he
will show up to confirm Jon's parentage
which is definitely a possibility
because he does have knowledge of that
information but I also think he could
show up to help with the night King
Howlin Reed has spent time at the Isle
of faces with the children of the forest
so perhaps he knows some things we don't
he could be one of those characters that
comes off the bench in the fourth
quarter and scores the game-winning
touchdown if he does show up next season
I don't think there's any way you could
kill him off so if we see him again and
he participates in battle in some way
I'm gonna say he will live to let me
know what you think of the list do you
agree with some of what I said or do you
disagree with anything in particular let
me know your thoughts or questions by
putting them down below in the comment
section I want to thank all of you for
watching today's video I'll really
appreciate that and I also want to thank
everyone on patreon for supporting my
channel have a great day I'll see you
again very soon
bye
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you